coup près du Conseil constitutionnel est
tombé hier comptant sur les 86 articles
de la loi immigration 32 ont été
retoqués pour des problèmes de forme
exactement le Conseil constitutionnel
qui estime que ces mesures sont des
cavaliers législatifs c'est un terme
qu'on entend beaucoup depuis hier c'est
dire c'estàd que leur objet s'éloignne
trop du texte initial pour être accepté
donc ce sont des ajouts qui ont été
faits notamment par la droite
sénatoriale et que donc le Conseil
constitutionnel retire du texte écarte
plus grave encore trois articles sont
censurés sur le fond car ils sont
contraires à la Constitution enfin vous
le voyez en bas deux articles font
l'objet d'une réserve d'interprétation
de la part du Conseil constitutionnel et
les articles qui ont été censurés pour
des problèmes de forme ce sont les
ajouts de la droite et du centre du
Sénat exactement on va voir un petit
détail de ce qui a été retoqué par le
conseil notamment le durcissement de
l'accès aux prestations sociales ça a
été enlevé du texte par le Conseil la
majorité de la droite et du centre
voulait conditionner les allocations à
une certaine durée de présence sur le
territoire 5 ans contre 6 mois
actuellement les juges ont donc dit que
cet article était trop éloigné du texte
initial autre mesure la 2ème le
durcissement du regroupement familial
avec une condition de séjour qui passait
à 24 mois au lieu de 18 actuellement et
enfin même chose pour le délit de séjour
illégal cela aussi ça a été retoqué
Oriane enfin la caution retour pour les
étudiants étrangers a également été
censurée la droite dit que les mesures
qu'elle a proposé sont plébiscité par
l'opinion publique d'où cette demande
DLR d'un nouveau projet de loi qui
reprennent ces 32 mesures qui sont
jugées comme des cavaliers législatifs
on va revenir là-dessus on va voir les
réactions politiques dans quelques
instants Benjamin mais et vous qui êtes
un éminent constitutionnaliste on a
entendu les LR dire mais c'est une
remise en cause du droit d'amendement
c'est ce que nous disait François Xavier
bami ne pas comprendre pourquoi des
mesures qui parlent du regroupement
familial qui parlent du droit du sol ou
qui parle de l'accès à des prestations
sociales pour des étrangers n'ont pas
été considérés comme ayant un rapport
avec l'immigration alors je dir il y a
deux aspects à ce sujet le premier
aspect c'est que cette décision elle est
pas si étonnante la notion de cavalier
législatif elle est présente dans la
jurisprudence du Conseil depuis très
très longtemps et des facto là-dessus le
conseil en fait pas un usage qui est un
usage particulièrement baroque en
réalité qu'est-ce que ça veut dire il
faut que c'est un trait direct avec
votre texte mais il faut également que
ça se rattache à une disposition
originelle du texte du Gouvernement en
gros parce que j'essaie de travailler la
pédagogie sur quelque chose de
totalement habitable depuis hier vous
avez un texte sur les légumes vous
faites un amendement sur le fromage rien
à voir avec les légumes vous êtes
d'accord très bien mais c'est de
l'alimentation
c'estimation mais malgré tout c'est un
texte sur les légumes vous avez un
article premier sur les sur les carottes
un article 2 sur les courgettes vous
faites un amendement sur les tomates la
tomate ne se rattache ni à la carotte ni
à la courgette donc même si on peut se
dire c'est un légume c'est quand même un
cavalier il faut que c trait à une
disposition originalement présente dans
le texte et ça évidemment c'est une
vision très restrictive de la notion de
cavalier donc ça c'est c'est le premier
aspect la la décision du Conseil
constituel elle est pas créée pour
l'occasion elle répond à une
jurisprudence constante en la matière
très restrictive l'autre élément c'est
que cette jurisprudence le Parlement a
quand même essayé de l'assouplir en 2008
on introduit notamment à l'article 45 et
bien un nouvel alinéa et on dit il faut
que les cavaliers ça existe certes mais
et bien il faut qu'il y ait un lien même
indirect avec le texte pour que ce soit
accepté le conseil depuis donc ça date
pas de cette décision a dit en fait bah
2008 vous avez introduit quelque chose
mais tient pas vraiment compte donc on a
une jurisprudence qu'on a essayé
d'assouplir que le Conseil n'a jamais
voulu assouplir et qui fait que en effet
la capacité des parlementaires à amender
à la marge d'un texte est très très
limité peut re considéré comm en clair
Benjamin est-ce qu' hierier on peut dire
comme le font les LR qui a eu une
décision politique de la part du Conseil
constitutionnel ou est-ce que vous dites
le Conseil constitutionnel a strictement
respecté le droit alors le Conseil
constitutionnel a strictement respecté
son interprétation de la notion av
législa précédente c'estàd que il a pas
créé il a pas créé il a pas créé une
jurisprudence très étonnante par rapport
à ce qu'il fait depuis des années il a
pas créé une jurisprudence spéciale
parce que là il voulait faire barrage à
telle ou telle disposition ça c'est pas
vrai en revanche on peut discuter cette
interprétation des qu législatif elle
est très discutable mais elle a pas été
créée pour l'occasion donc la décision
sur le fond paraît pas être politique on
peut être on peut discuter les décisions
du Conseil constitionel la décision sur
la réforme des retraite par exemple vous
avez des considérants qui sont hein je
rappelle aux téléspectateurs s veulent
le consulter le considérant 65 il est
très baroque là c'est pas le cas il y a
pas de baroque c'est c'est pas parce que
les LR vont vont assez loin Laurent
voquier il parle de coup d'État de droit
notamment bon est-ce que la décision est
politique ou pas moi je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent que le droit n'est
pas forcément à sexué politiquement et
que l'interprétation du droit malgré
tout a un impact politique et de toute
façon cette décision elle a forcément un
impact politique on peut quand même
s'étonner que par exemple sur le
regroupement familial on considère que
ça n'a pas un lien même direct avec la
question de l'immigration c'est quand
même courgette tomate courgette oui
enfin c'est vraiment je veux dire le le
la ligne est extrêmement est extrêmement
ténue ensuite on voit bien finalement
qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que va l'important
c'est de savoir ce que va retenir
l'opinion de cette j'allais dire de
cette de cette phase que l'on a traversé
alors à part un progrès grâce à Benjamin
et les interprétations que l'on peut
faire progrès en droit constitutionnel
et en droit parlementaire mais au-delà
de cela finalement ce qui ce qui ce qui
ce qui va à mon avis largement
apparaître c'est que il y a une forme
d'impuissance aujourd'hui du politique
une forme d'impuissance de l'État à
pouvoir traiter un certain nombre de
sujets qui sont des sujets qui sont
considérés comme prioritaires par
l'opinion publique et c'est là-dessus
aujourd'hui qu'argumente la droite pour
d'une certaine manière demander une
réforme constitutionnelle qui permette
en effet de contourner cette difficulté
qui aujourd'hui empêche en effet l'État
qui empêche le politique de pouvoir
traiter des sujets qui correspondent aux
attentes des Français tout simplement
ouais on va revenir sur les LR mais
puisque leslr parle de décision
politique on va écouter ce que répond
Laurent fabus le président du Conseil
constitutionnel il était ce matin
l'invité de la matinale de France Inter
c'est pas un choix que nous faisons nous
avons obligation de regarder si oui ou
non il y a un lien entre l'amendement et
le texte initial et quand il n'y a pas
de lien et bien nous sommes obligés de
dire c'est inconstitutionnel ça ne veut
pas dire je termine par là que la
disposition sur le fond nous la
censurions elle peut revenir sur le fond
et à ce moment-là nous dirons ce que
nous en pensons c'est important ce que
dit Laurent fabus en fait il y a pas eu
tellement de censure sur le fond de ce
texte à part quelques articles dans les
quotas migratoires mais par exemple on
parlait beaucoup de la préférence
nationale qui qui était dans ce texte
les les oppositions la qualifié de
préférence nationale sur l'accès aux
prestations sociales qui était
différencié là il y a pas eu de censure
sur le fond exactement en fait comme
vous et comme moi le Conseil n'aime pas
travailler pour rien c'est-à-dire que
quand il voit quelque chose et qu' se
dit c'est un cavalier législatif
qu'est-ce qu'il fait et bien il dit bah
j'ai pas besoin d'examiner sur le fond
étant donné que de toute façon je vais
censurer donc il met de côté il cherche
pas plusieurs raisons de retoquer une
mesure la première qui
arrive ça crée une forme d'ambiguïté
parce que en effet si vous prenez les
allocations familiales et cetera on a
des raisons de fond de penser que ça
pour pourrait être déclaré comme étant
inconstitutionnel mais aujourd'hui on ne
le sait pas et donc ce faisant si demain
on avait un nouveau texte sur
l'immigration et que ce texte bah ne
pait pas cavalier sur ce type de
disposition qui était présente le
Conseil pourrait nous dire c'est
inconstitutionnel ou pas pour l'instant
du point de vue de la manière dont on
conçoit la constitutionnalité des
dispositions relatives à l'immigration
bah la décision d'hier ne nous avance
pas beaucoup c'est ça et ça veut dire
que ça laisse la porte ouverte ça aurait
pu en tout cas laisser la porte ouverte
au gouvernement puisqueon a vu l'opinion
publique majoritairement favorable à ce
texte Laurent fabus il dit mais euh
représentez-les dans un autre texte et
puis à ce moment-là on dira ce qu'on en
pense ça veut dire que le gouvernement
il peut encore répondre à cette demande
de l'opinion publique et quelque part
c'est pas une si bonne décision de ça
pour Emmanuel Macron et Gérald armanin
bah clairement il y'y a pas que Laurent
fabus qui dit il y a la possibilité en
effet de légiférer à nouveau mais je
crois comprendre que les LR sont sur
cette ligne aujourd'hui vous avez votre
invité précédent monsieur bami qui d'une
certaine manière a en parlant justement
de la réforme future éventu de laame
considérer que il fallait intégrer dans
cette réforme là un certain nombre de
dispositions qui avaient été censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel ce jeudi donc
en effet aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
peut considérer que il a franchi un
obstacle qui était l'obstacle
parlementaire parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on on se retrouve dans quelle
situation on se retrouve avec le texte
initial qui était le texte tel qu'il
avait été présenté par Monsieur Darmanin
au au au Sénat et qui avait été bien
évidemment largement modifié par le
Sénat enfin en fait oui le texte initial
a été voté il a été d'une certaine
manière repris en compte tel qu'il en
sort de la de la décision du du Conseil
constitutionnel mais ce texte initiale
qui était d'ailleurs il faut le rappeler
soutenu par une majorité de Français euh
à l'époque et considéré comme
insuffisant considéré comme est
suffisant par les opinions considéré
comme est suffisant par les oppositions
euh
je ne vois pas aujourd'hui tel que les
choses sont en train de se préciser
Emmanuel Macron se relancer dans un
débat sur l'immigration mais c'est quand
même un problème c'est un problème dans
sa relation avec j'allais dire tout
simplement la le corps politique que
constitue la nation ouais d'autant que
Quentin la droite et le centre du Sénat
pousseent justement à ce qu'Emmanuel
Macron continue à légiférer sur cette
question oui les LR qui dénonce la
décision depuis hier des juges
constitutionnels le chef de fil des
sénateurs al brun Ret a parlé des motifs
très contestables du Conseil
constitutionnel sur les 32 articles
sensurés selon lui les Français voient
le Parlement réduit à l'impuissance
c'est le même type d'argument qu'on a
également entendu chez François Xavier
bami qui était votre invité à 8h écouter
un extrait de sa
réponse le Conseil cons prend une
responsabilité immense d'ailleurs celle
qui celle qui celle qui consiste à à
dire à tous les Français parce que c'est
ce qu'ils comprendront que en réalité
nos institutions
empêche notre propre état de se réarmer
pour reprendre une expression en vogue
aujourd'hui que nos institutions désarme
l'État et retire aux Français la
possibilité de décider de leur politique
migratoire c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons comme nous le faisons
depuis des années qu'un référendum
puisse avoir lieu sur la politique
migratoire et qui que nous puissions
réformer la consti de leur côté les
centristes ne critiquent pas directement
le Conseil constitutionnel c'est
là-dessus qu'il y a une différence
d'approche entre LR et centriste dès
hier ils ont annoncé dans un communiqué
C centrist qu'ils allaient déposer une
proposition de loi donc d'initiative
parlementaire dans les prochains jours
en reprenant je cite le communiqué une
grande partie de ces dispositions qui
avaient été adoptées tant par le Sénat
que par l'Assemblée nationale avec le
soutien du gouvernement insistent les
centristes écoutez à notre micro le
président de l'UDI le chef de fil des
sénateurs centristes hier RVA Marseille
le groupe Union centriste va déposer euh
rapidement dans les heures qui viennent
une proposition de loi qui reprendra une
partie de ses
dispositions afin qu'elle soit soumise à
nouveau au vote du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée je ne doute pas ayant été
déjà voté qu'elles le seront à nouveau
voilà on voit Emmanuel Macron et Gérard
haranin si on comprend leur déclaration
d'hier espérer tourner la page de cette
loi immigration bon la droite est le
centre du Sénat ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille exactement et c'est là où entre
guillemets l'opération loi immigration
devient quand même un désastre politique
pour le gouvernement parce qu'il y a
deux raisons première raison c'est que
il fallait pas parler d'immigration
pendant la campagne des européennes il
fallait tourner la page fallait changer
de dossier c'est raté parce que
évidemment maintenant on va peut-être
avoir des annonces de Gabriel natal sur
la me la droite va pas se contenter
d'une réforme de la me donc on va nveau
parler d'immigration sur un texte loi
ordinaire alors AC des propositions de
loi qui ont qu'une chance de passer
parce que déjà 32 articles dans une
proposition de loi il y a pas le temps
parlementaire pour les examiner en règle
générale avec des révisions
constitutionnelles bref on a armé
l'opposition pour que elle ait des
sujets à faire valoir en matière
d'immigration et c'était justement
l'objectif que ce ne soit pas le cas le
deuxiè élément vous savez l'un de vos
confrères m'a interrogé hier soir et a
posé une question extrêmement cruelle
pour Géral armanin il m'a demandé cette
loi en fait il reste rien à l'intérieur
cette question elle est très très
cruelle parce que si il reste le texte
de Gérald armanin c'està-dire que la
droite a réussi à euh donner une
signification à cette loi qui n'était
pas celle du texte d'origine elle a
réussi à faire que les dispositions
qu'elle avait introduites symbolisent
beaucoup beaucoup plus cette loi que les
dispositions originales de Gérald
armanin l'idée que le gouvernement
aurait aujourd'hui un bilan en matière
d'immigration c'est quelque chose qui
risque d'être assez peu ressenti par les
Français parce que les dispositions
qu'ils avaient en tête sur lesquelles
ils s'étaient accroché et bien elles ont
disparu ça veut dire qu'il y a que des
perdant le le gouvernement parce que
l'opinion publique a l'impression qu'il
reste rien de cette loi la droite qui
s'est fait retoquer ses dispositions la
gauche qui de toute façon ne voulait pas
de ce texte et l'opinion publique qui
attendait autre chose je sais pas si a
des perdant en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que je retiens c'est que la fièvre
sur le sujet d'immigration c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ne va pas
retomber et ce qui en fait pose problème
pour Géral d'manec qui veut présenter ce
texte comme un texte de fermeté va
apparaître finalement pour une grande
partie de l'opinion publique comme un
texte de faiblesse ensuite moi je pense
que sur le plan politique oui il y a
quand même un gagnant le gagnant c'est
le rassemblement national d'une certaine
manière qui est est c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire dispose d'une antériorité
historique sur ces sujets et qui va
faire la démonstration en creux ben de
l'impuissance aujourd'hui des pouvoirs
publics des différentes majorités à
pouvoir gérer cette question migratoire
qui constitue quand même un enjeu
important dans toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion qui se succèdent très
rapidement très rapidement en effet le
seul vainqueur pour moi c'est rassemble
nationale pour deux raisons la première
raison c'est que Ben tout ce dont on a
parlé concernant la préférence nationale
et cetera a quand même été soutenu par
une majorité à dominante centriste et
n'a pas été à ce stadelà censuré sur le
fond par le Conseil constitutionnel donc
on peut plus considérer que ces mesures
sont à ce point tabou et radioactive de
l'autre côté et bien le RN pourra dire
regardez LR a tendu la main au
gouvernement ça n'a pas marché et donc
la seule possibilité la seule alternance
la seule alternative c'est nous et ça
évidemment ça crédibilise et le logiciel
de normalisation et le logiciel
d'alternance donc c'est plutôt encore
une fois Marine Le Pen qui gagne allez
avant de se quitter c'est vendredi vous
le savez on vous emmène découvrir notre
patrimoine et notre addition dans 6 mois
jour pour jour sera donné le coup
d'envoi des Jeux olympiques de Paris N a
pas c les athlètes qui se préparent
Cécile sexou nous emmène à Bayonne dans
une PME Le Bret français cette
entreprise a été choisie pour produire
le couvre-chef officiel des Jeux
Olympiques après avoir fourni ceux de la
Coupe du monde de rugby et tout un
savoirfire dans cette PME bayonnaise on
fabrique des béret depuis près de 10 ans
une jeune entreprise mise sous les
projecteurs l'an dernier elle a été
choisie comme fournisseur officiel de la
coupe du monde de rugby oui on pour
participer à un événement comme ça avec
euh avec un produit typiquement français
100 % fait en France oui c'est une vraie
fierté d'avoir travailler sur
cette sur cette sur événement une fierté
pour thbao le chef d'atelier il a dû se
retrousser les manches pendant plusieurs
mois et réorganiser la production il a
fallu bah déjà développer le produit
donc il a fallu également bah commencer
à sourcer la laine il a fallu aussi
commencer à se staffer aussi donc on a
on a revu les équipes on augmenté la
taille équip des effectifs doublés 30000
ventes supplémentair et un chiffre
d'affair à plus 60% la succès story ne
s'arrête pas là car le savoirfaire du B
français a aussi séduit les
organisateurs
des de la position du patch c'est
bon les priers échantillons pour les
Olympi donc une version enfant avec
mascotte BR la version adulte
on a le beret avec le logo officiel j
2024 et la version en fait en
paralympique les premières livraisons
sont prévu au mois d'avril tiib ajuste
les derniers détails avec ses équipes le
fil pour
le pas tropvec le blanc ça va et puis la
position est très bonne il faut que on
finisse de développer les prototypes
rapidement et qu'on se lance dans la
production a déjà commencé le tricot
ouais voilà et et le reste va suivre
très rapidement ouais et donc forcément
il va falloir embaucher encore comme
pour la Coupe du Monde des CDD pour pour
sur sur croix d'activité l'entreprise ne
souhaite pas communiquer sur le nombre
de commandes mais chaque Béré pour les
jeux sera produit selon les règles de
l'art tricoté par ces grosses machines
dans les ateliers chaque bonnet est
vérifié à la main donc on vérif la
qualité du produit si on n pas des trous
près d'une dizaine d'étapes l'attendent
ensuite le feutrage en machine
l'enformage et au bout de la chaîne il
est une nouvelle fois scruté par le
regard connaisseur des couturières un
savoir-faire une qualité pour un
accessoire de mode typiquement français
c'est un SAB j'ai vécu à l'étranger donc
oui on nous éménagine tous français avec
avec un Bret donc effectivement pour les
étrangers quand ils viennent en France
le Le Ber et l'accessoire ultime en
français après après la baguette un
symbole aux couleurs des GI mais surtout
un souvenir que pourrait ramener les
étrangers dans leur valise après la
compétition qutin vous votre ça ça vous
plaît ça vous plaî les B ouais non alors
moi c'est pas trop mon F mais bon je
dois reconnaître que c'est c'est c'est
bien c'est fabriqué français c'est beau
c'est maison
allezendend prendra des ver pour les en
attendant regarde des quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
Quentin évidemment la une de la presse
régionale ce matin c'est la mobilisation
des agriculteurs exactement c'est à la
Une de très nombreux titres ce matin
Stop ou Encore se demande un sty le
courrier picar à Amien la mobilisation
ne faiblit pas raconte le populaire du
centre à limoge les agriculteurs
accentuent la pression titre le journal
de Lyon et l'Union àins qui parle de
tension qui monte d'un cran voit donc
toute l'attente accumulé un mouvement
qui devient de plus en plus radical dit
la presse ce matin la FNS qui parle de
55000 manifestants partout en France
hier et tous les regards sont bien sûr
tournés vers Gabriel Atal attendu en
ocitanie voilà exactement le Premier
ministre se rend en HauteGaronne pour
dévoiler les annonces du gouvernement
c'est donc une journée cruciale comment
Gabriel àal va-t-il répondre à la
première crise depuis son arrivée à
metigon Le Télégramme le journal breton
qui parle de PIST du gouvernement des
annonces très concrètes sur le GNR le
gazoel Non Routier vous en parliez
Arnaud ou encore en matière de
simplification par exemple j'ai lu dans
le journal un outil pour éviter que les
entrepreneurs et bien né à renvoyer les
mêmes documents à différentes
administrations c'est raconté dans les
pages inintérieur du télégram il y a
d'autres une sur cette crise agricole
voilà au total on en a compté 18 nous ce
matin c'est dire l'importance du sujet
en France dans les départements tous ces
titres qui ont réalisé des reportages et
qui racontent ce qui se dit au milieu
des blocages on notera l'appel de José
Bovet a rester pacifique à la une du
Midi Libre Journal de Montpellier autre
actualité on en a parlé ce matin c'est
la loi immigration oui et maintenant se
demande ainsi ni ce matin avec cette
analyse intéressante résumé en une
phrase la censure partielle par le
Conseil constitutionnel satisfait
l'exécutif sur le fond mais risque de
l'isoler encore plus politiquement allez
on termine avec un sujet plus léger oui
on termine souvent avec un sujet plus
léger c'est la touttin calmé ça oui et
puis en plus Mathias Arz en parlait dès
hier dans cette revue de presse le
festival de la bande dessinée d'angoulem
qui a ouvert ses portes hier ce matin on
voit Rachid adati à la une de la
Charente Libre la ministre de la Culture
est en visite officielle demain samedi
au festival en attendant elle est sur un
traac
ça va desbll titre le journal merci
Quentin merci pour cette revue de presse
Arnaud la nouvelle une de la revue
politique et parlementaire on la regarde
oui rapidement le dossier consacré au
travail il nous a semblé que 6 mois
après l'adoption de la loi retraite un
an et demi après le covid qui a changé
la relation au travail pour nombre de
Français qu'il était intéressant de
pouvoir se pencher sur ce sujet et on
aura l'occasion d'en parler évidemment
de nombreux vendredi merci Arnaud merci
Benjamin d'avoir été avec nous merci
Quentin merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve lundi on vous souhaite un
très bon
weekend